I read about this British man who is who
was being held in Egypt after officials
said that he sexually assaulted a police
officer how and this man claims that all
he did was at the airport security when
he was leaving Egypt he had like at the
final checkpoint it was standard
procedure for him to be patted down by a
security officer so then after he got
pad patted down he just patted the
officers back gently and that
immediately what that made him get
locked up are we sure he wasn't like
that well the officials claimed that
they had CCTV footage to support their
version of events which was him being
like him sexually assaulting the officer
huh that's his account that's what you
see he's saying and then the officials
are saying that he was oh well it's like
he made sexual gestures at a police
officer but the officials were refusing
to release the footage we have evidence
where is it at it's Egypt we don't have
to show you [ __ ] don't worry about it
who is he does he have any position of
power or no he was just a tourist a
tourist you wanted to see the pair [ __ ]
so his name is Tony I heard everyone
gets scammed by the cameras
oh he had been - he had been to Egypt
like 10 times in his lifetime like he
had been there a lot I do want to go to
Egypt everyone says you get you do the
camel ride and then they scam you oh
well how do they fam you overcharge
so just bring extra Meir there's a lot
of tourists Trapster worth it yeah I'm
down to be trapped in the tourists reps
really yes I love them sometimes I bring
extra money just so I could get scanned
by those things have you ever been to
meteor crater in Arizona
no that's the tourist trap and it's
really fun all right then yeah oh I
think so it's the big one yeah yeah and
it looks like Grand Canyon y'all never
seen the Grand Canyon Wow neither
we're Lee trader that's how white-trash
my family is pact escena yep so he went
too easy up in you guys yeah well maybe
maybe he's in denial hey that's pretty
good actually good now you wanted to
hear more I don't hate you for that one
well yeah he was being held without like
they're saying in inhumane conditions he
was sleeping on the floor not being
liked not no blankets he his family gave
him food and stuff and they didn't they
waited two days later to give him the
supplies that his food this family gave
him okay but what did the airline people
do to him
airport security TS sync every time I go
to TSA I get patted down like a
[ __ ] yeah every single time I
get the full hand pat-down you don't go
to those no I go to the shoe but then
they pulled me inside and they do the
full pat-down they touch my dick they
touch my [ __ ] legs
your penis is too big a stupid are they
like what is this hiding showing up on
the x-ray so stupid that can't be a dick
that decided be some man smuggling a
bazooka you listen it's a pipe bomb in
there there has to be some kind of a
[ __ ] adjustment they can make to
this machine so that I don't get flagged
in no I think it's the big dick and in
it no and then they they think that
sponge my hands for nuclear facility I
get that to Pat me down because it feels
like a nice little gentle massage if you
make if you make a lot of money I just
did this research right cuz I was like I
don't want to go through security I
don't want to wait how much does it cost
to get a private jet right so if you get
some ice we're in something very small
it's 1,600 to 3,000 per hour oh well if
you go mommy smallest so let's say
you're ballin it's nothing yeah a medium
or whatever would be around four to six
thousand get this though a full-sized
big jet like make a Boeing one of those
like a like a 737 737 okay would be like
13,000 an hour
these are all our prices yes so imagine
if you're going to Europe or Asia or
whatever that's a 16-hour flight Wow or
twelve
our flight or whatever what's the math
on that 13 times 11 or 12 oh that's like
over there 100 grand
50 grand maybe one way oh my goodness
that's you and your crew but yeah I was
gonna say if it's if it's 1,600 an hour
for the smaller ones right and let's say
like eight of us went to Vegas yes but
to arouse a person that might be Peller
one because it was the cheapest one just
me the extra oh like the uncomfortable
flight you feel every single turbulence
yeah we'd have to probably get like that
three to four thousand one Jesse it's
cool I'm done now yes it's pretty sweet
to bear
yes sure do it Bart dady right I did
with my dad
he thought I was balling he thought I
travel like that all the time damn is
that what you guys do I might I'm only
taking you because it's Father's Day you
should say yes but isn't that still
expensive no it's it's it's it's it's
almost the same as going through a
regular [ __ ] like what a hundred bucks
or so yeah it may be let me like a
hundred fifty is 100 dude you skip
security bro there's you walk right in
for that terror is sitting next to you
because it's cheaper to do a terrorist
well you'll know cuz he'll look like a
terrorist I think it took my dad a Vegas
it's pretty cool yeah recently we should
go hey inmate let's go to Vegas hell yet
I went on a killer craft roll by the way
I didn't tell you I feel like competing
on you our 15 classrooms rolling I was
hitting the point I was hitting it was
bad and tired and how much did you make
Oh like four bucks I mean [ __ ] but to
[ __ ] Phil DeFranco way he does it
1,700 G he plays for fun yeah I play to
take over the casino right what's the
most you make playing craps oh you don't
know
thousands word I forgot what though I'm
always scared of like commit to that
[ __ ] why you're so rich in heavy played
craps I'm like I'm a little bit hoo-wee
you gotta shop with us we have fun the
thing is we need to feel like a little
bit of risk in life yeah you right yeah
it's important for your success at all -
okay
I feel risk when I'm freaking shaving my
[ __ ] - Stan were you shaving it with
that's gambling for geo she's at the
casino
yeah [ __ ] she's like oh crap oh crap
you never cut it cut what your [ __ ] I
did once I don't hear you scream oh
there was bed
oh that's gamblin that's her idea of
Vegas that's why she doesn't need to go
to Vegas she's never come to Savin my
puss it has forever critiqued your [ __ ]
Minh like I think you can feel this more
whiskey yeah that's good nice are you
near-sighted now I know I think we know
yeah yeah me too
anyway back to the Egypt story yeah fine
was that where we're at that's what
we're doing here all right so initially
they said that they were gonna detain
him for four days pending an
investigation because remember they
refused to show the footage of him we're
things are extending it to a further 15
days even though he had not been charged
with anything so that's when they turned
to social media and they were asking
people to help and to call their members
of parliament and try to do something
for Tony and eventually they were able
to come to the agreement of paying a
1,000 pound bail and that's when they
were like okay you're good to go Wow he
did a bribe um maybe when I come on in
he had a whole lawyer and everything and
they also had like the consulate people
involved and it was a big ordeal but it
was because of the fact that they got
social media attention that's why his
team we're saying see how [ __ ] up this
is if he didn't get any any attention
from the public he would have still been
sitting in it it's scary man cuz some
countries like I don't know we I think
we don't realize how much they can ruin
the [ __ ] out of I feel like so grateful
like I mean I'm
in America when especially freedom of
speech [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah when we went to
Morocco we were leaving we had a German
in our luggage was Morocco scary no it
was fine it was just leaving Morocco
they checked our baggage and they saw
that we had that little tiny thematic my
son needs a Christmas present in the
night see ya but you know cuz I got piss
with the officials and I'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me you're stealing from
us right now inspector there were
moments where they like yeah
wait they speak French out there so
French I ya know in this okay no
comprende so then once I was getting
really upset with them the official
ended up coming back and was like you
know if you had this drone without a
permit in Egypt you would have been in
prison for two years
oh my god luckily I'm not in Egypt
Morocco we only steal from people and
let you guys go you know Egypt it's
worse so damn deal with like it makes it
better we fell in love with Morocco but
that final experience of them stealing
our drum because then they gave us
paperwork's and they were like okay go
online and then submit it and then we'll
ship it to you or whatever which we did
and obviously they didn't you know you
should is it I'm an influencer and you
ever Morocco is doomed
wait till I tweet do you'll even [ __ ]
know yet you see all these followers
here yeah a smart call yeah pretty soon
as a hit tweet hahaha so crows that
people actually didn't like that um that
shouldn't even happen um I mean it was
just like in Mexico I went with a like
years ago I went to you just TJ just
Tijuana with the homies right and PD
flow he's like you know TJ was fun
before it got dangerous so what we was
like right when you cross the border all
the bars and [ __ ] you know no no you
know what's up sweetie food so people oh
you know he looks white right but he's
like [ __ ] fluent
why didn't I yeah
loulou Mexican he's like uh represent
right so um we were there we're walking
around at the homie and the homie had a
beer but it was open and a cop came up
to us and was like I was like yo you're
not allowed to have that open bottle of
beer give me $200 right now or I'll take
you to jail
oh we're good and we were like oh [ __ ]
Peter was like was like hey look man
like in Spanish was like look I'm
Mexican I know what you're doing like
like relax and the guy was like oh okay
nevermind you guys didn't bargain like
I'll give you ten bucks no no Peter was
is like hey man look dude I'm Mexican I
know I know what's up okay listen I know
what's going on I'll teach you a really
cool magic trick I love magic
check this out and then the cop was like
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] bruja okay cool rudia
and then we went to a strip club
no actually and then a guy was like
trying to guess no strip club and we're
like no thank you and then the dude
called me gay and then those are not
yeah he was like uh we didn't even go
cuz he you know I said no thanks and he
was like so good you don't like naked
girls I was like we're good mazing this
dude got a little sugar in his tank you
don't like naked girl with bro relax
there we go see you have sugar your dick
I don't have sugar mine
what does that mean because he's
probably thinking you're gonna be like
very complicated gay Joker what's
shooting a tank you got a shooting tank
means like you're like you're gay how do
you say that what you never heard that
before
I saw hot English hozuki ensue tango
close the vowels are really close what a
complex gay joke there for the game now
I totally what I went to the circle I
don't know why I didn't go
[Music]